Oh, it is time for Drew's News!
And with me at the desk,
every person's dream pilot, Ross Mathews.
Yes, hi, everybody!
Hi, hi, everybody!
(audience cheering)
Hi.
I said girl once,
and then I was like, "No, it just has to be person."
Every person on the planet.
If you're alive, you want Ross, period.
Okay, I'll take it, thank you.
I do.
Oh.
Okay, first up, we know weddings
cost a pretty penny.
Oh my god.
And we found one interesting way to attack that bill.
Now I found this story quite controversial.
Okay, go.
So "Newsweek" reports
that a person on Reddit says their friend, Katie,
is a bride to be
and she recently told her friends
that she'd be sending around her Venmo account
so that they could "chip in" for the wedding costs.
Mhmm.
Ross?
Yes?
Thoughts?
You're about to get married.
I am, and, Katie, girl, I feel your pain.
This Venmo, I'm about to pass around a bucket
here in the audience, a collection.
Seriously, I mean, I thought to myself
when I first found out how much the flowers
were for a wedding,
can I hold a bake sale to raise funds?
I see flowers on the side of the road.
You wanna charge me what?
It is shocking how much these things are.
So, Katie, get your friends to all chip in.
Genius, Katie, genius.
I wonder if she could pose it
like as the wedding registry?
Like is there something a little kind of strange
about Venmo and a wedding?
Like a registry.
Like, "If you put in,
this would buy a bouquet of flowers at table eight."
I think sometimes people need to know
where their money is going.
"If you put your money in,
it will provide this at this beautiful ceremony."
I think that's lovely,
but give me cold, hard cash!
All right, thank you so much.
(audience clapping)
I'm kidding, sort of.
All right, hey, next up, we got a money saving tip.
Should we put your Venmo in a lower third?
My god, no.
I mean, I'm kidding, I don't really want help,
but I don't wanna shame Katie, her friend, for doing this.
And I don't wanna shame Katie either.
If I was your friend,
I would just wanna know
that I was purchasing a certain something.
Understood.
How about your chicken dinner at my wedding?
How about that's what you're purchasing?
All right, next up,
we've got a money saving tip all the way from Japan.
Ooh.
Yeah.
And we've got spring cleaning here, right?
You always hear people saying that.
But in Japan, apparently,
they love a good end-of-the-year scrub.
They call it oosouji.
And "Real Simple" reports
for a natural and cheap household cleaner,
you know what they use?
An orange.
True, this is a tip from the book, "Simplicity at Home,"
by Yumiko Sekine, all about Japanese cleaning techniques.
Step one, get an orange, and then eat it.
Step two, save the peel, boil the peel in water.
Let it simmer for like 15 minutes,
and you've got a cleaner for the kitchen or any surface.
Look, right here, we have one here, that's yours.
There's an inner peace that comes with cleaning.
Oh, a postcard.
So this is my happy place.
And I feel like there's really only so many things
that we can control in life.
Sure, look at her.
So cleaning is something
that also is within your control
to make something clean and not a mess.
Like messes affect your emotions.
Hey, look, Drew, orange you glad I cleaned the desk?
By the way, this smells incredible.
(audience clapping)
Stupid.
Woo!
Okay, next up.
We get a little pep in our step
every time we save money,
and I can be riding high on a good promo code for days.
And "Vice" reports that the public library
is tapping into this
with new receipts that show you how much
that you have saved by borrowing books,
instead of buying them.
Oh, they're keeping track of that, huh?
They track all the books that you've taken out in a year,
calculate how much they paid for them brand new,
and show you the total amount
that you've saved in the year
or in your lifetime of borrowing.
And it can be up to tens of thousands
over the course of the lifetime.
So this is amazing.
Yeah, do you go to the library?
My mom always checked out books at the library,
but I haven't been.
I'm in trouble
with my library.
I checked out like a best seller
and forgot to return it,
and I got a bunch of late fees.
They were very cross with me.
And I know them,
like I go in there in person and like talk with them.
And, yeah, they were disappointed in me.
Oh god, that's the worst,
they're disappointed.
No, not in a mean way!
What did they say to you?
Just glad it's back.
How late were you returning it?
Like four weeks.
Well, now that's fair.
Come on, life gets in the way.
I don't go to the library for that very reason.
Clap of hands, who goes to the library in the audience?
(audience clapping)
Really?
Oh, that makes me so happy.
Well, apparently, you are doing
a very fiscally responsible move.
And I also just like love that shared scent
and the tactile knowing that like other people
have gone on this adventure too.
I don't feel that way when I sit in an airplane seat,
I'm not like, "Ooh, all the people."
I'm more like.
(audience laughing)
But a library book,
I'm like.
Ha, ha, ha, you're in it.
Mmm, we all did this together.
(upbeat music)